visiblement ce soir donc le nez mans un
roumain monsieur nicolas ceausescu ne
maîtrise plus tout la situation dans son
pays d'ailleurs le discours du dictateur
comme on vous l'a dit tout à l'heure a
été interrompu à plusieurs reprises par
des manifestants dans la matinée le
problème de la roumanie finalement c'est
moins de sortir du communisme que le se
débarrasser du mégalomane qui la dirige
avec sa famille car vous ne le savez
peut-être pas mais en roumanie ceausescu
premier porte le charmant surnom ne vous
tenez regardez bien de fils plus aimé du
peuple génie des carpates danube de la
pensée firmament de l'humanité toutes
ces choses toutes simples
on commençait donc dans une cordonnerie
cas ça a été son premier métier son
portrait zylberstein 16 ans de pouvoir
absolu pour deux tristes records fer de
la roumanie le pays le plus pauvre
d'europe s'adjuger le titre de tirant le
plus unanimement décrié le petit
cordonnier commence une carrière de
discrètes apparatchiks jusqu au
politburo quand il succède à john joue
day en mars 65 c'est presque un inconnu
un animal de courte durée ceausescu se
distingue d'abord par sa politique
étrangère différente de celle de verser
des autres pays du pacte
première entorse aux contrats 67 la
roumanie est la seule à ne pas rompre
avec israël après la guerre des six
jours
mais surtout 68 chez vous chez secours
refuse d'envoyer ses soldats mater le
printemps de prague
enfin au plus fort du conflit sino
soviétique
lucas reste respectera longtemps une
stricte neutralité entre ses deux grands
frères relative indépendance extérieur
donc vitrine pour chaouchi se fout à
destination de l'étranger rideau de
fumée pour les roumains qui en
connaissent le prix une dictature
intérieur quasiment sans égal dans le
monde
c'est le culte de la personnalité tout
en roumanie chante la gloire de chaouchi
secoue le danube de la pensée qui vécut
pleut parfois la lumière pour que
l'élève mais pas vous c'est le népotisme
chercher secours est bâti un clan son
clan à l'intérieur de la nomenclature à
au pouvoir sa femme elena et numéro deux
du régime
sa fille et son fils son frère et ses
deux beaux frères font partie de
l'équipe dirigeante
c'est enfin la répression un roumain sur
10 appartient à la police politique ou
mesure mieux le courage des quelques
dissidents tel dounia corner dépression
économique avec les émeutes de la faim à
brasov en 86 le peuple réclame du pain
ceausescu lui envoie des canons
répression nationaliste en transylvanie
pour les deux millions de roumains
d'origine hongroise ceausescu les a
privés de tous leurs droits à raser huit
mille villages et fermer la frontière
avec la hongrie voisine
aujourd'hui toutes les frontières sont
fermées le rideau de fer existe bel et
bien à l'est mais entre la roumanie et
ses voisins plus délirant encore la
destruction du centre historique de
bucarest à la place des ruelles et des
églises ceausescu est riche sa propre
ville de béton pour que l'histoire de la
roumanie ne commence qu'avec lui
dernière parodie qui ferait sourire si
fait et le cinéma
le 14e congrès du parti communiste le
mois dernier 6e réélection pour le conte
du quator comme les cinq autres elle
suffit-elle l'humanité la même unanimité
présente aujourd'hui dans les rues pour
demander son départ
bon